we continue our team coverage regarding
the pause of the johnson and johnson
vaccine
christian casares joining us live from
our newsroom with how southern nevada
health leaders are addressing that
problem
brian health officials say people who
got the johnson johnson vaccine should
keep
a close watch on any type of side
effects now as of monday
47 000 johnson and johnson vaccines
have been administered right here in
clark county through sites like the
cashman center community events
and efforts via the city of north las
vegas during a meeting this morning with
the health district
dr fermin leguin addressed concerns
about vaccination fears
and impacts to the state's vaccination
campaign he said all vaccines are safe
he also reminded everyone that the halt
comes from rare blood clotting
in six cases all women ages 6 18 i'm
sorry 18 to 48
who developed illnesses shortly after
getting the shot none
are from nevada the vaccines that
we are offering is pfizer moderna
and those vaccines have been proved to
be
effective and also to be safe and
and those those numbers that we
have locally here with more than one
million doses
already administered even though the
risks are minimal dr lewin says people
who got the jansen vaccine should
monitor themselves for
any symptoms including severe headaches
abdominal pain and shortness of breath
now if you had blood clots or other
medical issues in the past
and have concerns about the vaccine it's
best that you talk
to your doctor now all scheduled events
to administer this vaccine have been
cancelled
now there will be a meeting with health
officials according to dr lewin tomorrow
where more recommendations are expected
to roll out christian casa is 8 news now
christian thank you